cet endroit sur l'avenue l'île de france
à saint-andré film et il y a quelques
années abrite désormais un immeuble
c'est précisément là en 1936 cailleux la
première célébration du 20 décembre
à l'origine cet homme gabriel virapin la
mairie de saint-andré lui refuse tout
rassemblement
qu'à cela ne tienne il décide de
l'organiser dans sa cour gabriel rapin
effectivement et le premier
du beau du travail à vouloir organiser
une
manifestation officielle publique dans
les rues en faveur des affranchis des
descendeurs d'affranchis 2148 en 1936
c'est la première manifestation
mais il n'aura pas l'autorisation du
maire léopold matin il a fallu attendre
un siècle pour qu'enfin le démantèlement
de lescar âge soit célébrée à la réunion
la personnalité de gabriel virapin est
surtout associée au syndicat des à
l'heure de pioche mais il ya peu de
domaines où ce militant de la première
heure ne laisse son empreinte employés
de commerce transitaires à madagascar
responsable des dockers à l'ancienne
pointe des galets industriel
journalistes et il a été conseiller
municipal au port et à sainte-suzanne
pourtant sa mémoire n'apparaît pas
beaucoup dans les livres d'histoire mais
je pense aussi que c'était parce que
c'était un le premier homme de couleur
qui a quand même une certaine réussite
non pas la réussite sociale mais la
réussite aussi familial
je pense que c'est important de dire que
tous ces enfants
à l'époque c'était extrêmement rare on
fait des études ont été diplômés avec
gabriel virapin le statut de l'ouvrier
est valorisée il suit de près
l'application des 40 heures de travail
par semaine et met fin aux corvées de
fourrage que devait fournir le salarié
en faveur de son employeur en plus de
son travail
héritage de l' esclavage gabriel virapin
tient sa révérence en 1973 après avoir
sensiblement modifié les rapports entre
les employeurs et les travailleurs